адже трохи і apple екшен для міністр
оборони урсула фон дер ляйєн то генсека
нато йенса столтенберга
розлучення вони 4 батальйоні у середній Європі
патча лося поспішаю на пі в руку не матчі
на відео та активну роль у формуванні
континенту на ту у латвійці зателефонувати
регулярний пригрозив силоміць адекватні
створення в ікону в обороні функції all
in 1 година ми читку показуємо ще на під
на одну Україну для вас означають і монопод
і на всі 28 crane блонд сенсей
розростання весь когось у підрозділі
україна hbo латте це польші стала
реакцію на ти дали більше за неспокій.
crying він зайвого су-100 брюс ван та
вечора та до грози з боку русі та розвиток
пу день нас видних кордонах на спокій і
рожд україн альянсу під листом сара він
просто прайд понад місяць росія
розмістила в Калінінграді ракетні
комплекси іскандер то припливла диву роки
xii США про утилізацію стрункого
плутонію такої ж Росії продовжу ж
доставили золота sedna україну на дачі
весь комусь фінансову хитрим курс
сепаратистам такі ідеї не знаєш затишно
пробу таннер вигляд наші види але син її
білле шифре тбо чого нами новий транш
арешту при дтп обличчі акрі мені меч і не по
одному батальйону наді шлють до балтії крок
вона дата Великобританії і дайте а про
передислокацію за голом 4000 ризикових
служба всіх різними broen транспорту риф
про те ракетних комплексів то їм шоу в
школу з броня для Москви посилаючи
злочинності на те так близько до
російських кордонів і однозначну
провокацію теж у роті вчи код і контр
заходь у кремля